welcome today I'm going to be talking
about bioinformatics and quantitative
genomics in cervical cancer screening
circle cancer is a very complex disease
and much has been written and discussed
about the various ways to most
appropriately diagnose and treat
cervical cancer to date that has relied
on the Papen Nicholas screen which is a
morphologic assessment of cells taken
from the cervix that technology and
assay has been around since nineteen
forty nine more recently the use of HPV
or human papillomavirus has come into
play as a means of determining who is at
risk of cervical cancer screening but as
i'll show you throughout this discussion
cervical cancer is a complex process
that goes well beyond morphologic
changes of cells in the cervix and goes
beyond the presence or absence of human
papillomavirus although human papilloma
virus has been implicated in over
ninety-nine percent of circle cancers
and the mechanism by which human
papillomavirus contributes to cervical
cancer pathogenesis has been elucidated
we are still in the early stages of
deploying that technology in our
day-to-day clinical screening of
cervical cancer I urge everybody to
submit questions as we go through the
talk and those will be answered at the
end during a Q&A session one of
technology is going to talk about is a
technology developed here at in cell DX
a technology that we call 3 DX this
technology is one that
that multiplex multiple different types
of analyses into a single assay when you
hear the term multiplex in molecular
diagnostics you're mostly consider
people who have technologies capable of
detecting multiple rnase multiple DNA's
multiple snips or on the other hand
proteomics which detects multiple
proteins or even analyses that allow
detection of different morphometric
aspects of the cell here I'm going to be
talking about a technology that
incorporates all of those facets in
helping to elucidate some of the more
complex mechanisms of cervical cancer
and cancer in general I'm not going that
into greater detail so we're in the
e-rep multiplexing with exciting new
technology such as next-gen sequencing
but however we we are very limited in
our ability to do what we call
heterogeneous multiplexing that is
combining a multiplex assay that looks
at DNA messenger RNA proteins and
morphology all at the same time and with
a throughput and workflow that is
compatible with a clinical diagnostics
laboratory and ultimately patient care
this salloum achsah proach in coop them
described today really incorporates
heterogenous multiplexing as I'll show
you where able to detect messenger RNA
DNA and various morphometric parameters
of a cell all at the same time without
destroying the cell most other molecular
diagnostic technologies as you know all
involved lie sing the cell recovering
nucleic acids and then analyzing the
nucleic acids in downstream applications
in terms of circle cancer we've seen
progress over the last 10 to 20 years
since the time that they discovered that
HPV was associated with cervical cancer
in the late 90s we saw the the
appearance of hybrid capture 2 which is
the first essay based on liquid
hybridization that was capable of
detecting a high-risk human papilloma
virus DNA in the mid to early 2000s
liquid based sampling of cervical
cytology specimens came along this was a
significant improvement over the old
methodology of doing a pap smear where a
spatula spread cells on the glass slide
you were able to look at those cells
morphologically but do little else on to
that clinical sample liquid-based
cervical cytology as well as
liquid-based cytology and other body
parts for other cancers this really
allowed us to apply all the current
molecular methodologies to a single
sample type and perform a multitude of
analyses as I'll describe throughout
this discussion in the late 2000s and
into 2010 we started to see HPV genotype
come back into the picture in other
words was there in importance in terms
of the HPV type that was infecting
individual beyond just determining
whether it was a high-risk type now at
that time there was also a multitude of
papers that came out to say that
high-risk types all have the
capabilities of producing cancer and
whether you have one type or another how
much value added information does that
give the clinician and art in an attempt
to treat or triage that individual
what that left was a huge gap HPV
methodologies for cervical cancer
screening are highly sensitive with
sensitivities over ninety percent for
high-grade disease as determined by
histology however the specificity in the
range of twenty to thirty percent let
the door open for a very high
false-positive atira clinical false
positivity rate which of course led to
inordinate amount of downstream invasive
procedures such as copas copy and biopsy
to then determine exactly the treatment
path in that particular patient along
those lines we developed an assay that
quantified the e6 e7 messenger RNA now
when HPV was discovered to determine our
to be associated with cervical cancer
was also found that e 67 anka genes
which are carried by the HPV genome were
also critical to the transformation of
cells the development of preclin
cervical cancer lesions and ultimately
to cervical cancer the other important
aspect of pulling in a specific
biomarker for cellular transformation is
it took the specificity of our cervical
cancer screening methodologies from the
twenty to thirty percent rage into the
85 to 95 percent range whereas you can
now have a combination of tests to
screen for cervical cancer that had an
acceptable performance profile of 90
plus percent sensitivity and 90 plus
percent specificity this diagram and
these schematics on the next few slides
illustrate the mechanism by which HPV
causes cervical cancer
HPV infect cells as a circular episome
resides in the cytoplasm and for the
most part those cells with HPV infection
get cleared over time by the immune
system especially in younger women under
certain circumstances the HPV genome
integrates into the host chromosome
during integration two genes are deleted
in the HPV genome one being the l1 gene
which I'll talk about in a moment but
most importantly the et gene of HPV is
deleted what does that do well II 2 is a
negative regulator for the oncogenes e6
and e7 so doing integration and
following a to deletion the HPV anka
genes are highly overexpressed going
from a copier to Purcell during a normal
life cycle to over five to seven hundred
copies per cell and that's the event
some of these newer technologies such as
architect or detecting in the cell now
following e6 e7 mrna upregulation the e6
e7 proteins are made which bind to p53
and RB tumor suppressor genes the
inactivation of cellular tumor
suppressor genes leads to cell cycle
dysregulation and ultimately invasion
and cervical cancer now this mechanism
as you can see is much more
sophisticated than just the mere
presence or absence of HPV so we need to
get beyond just determining whether or
not you have an HPV infection if we
really want to have tests that accurate
accurately diagnose and triage women
with circle cancer and pre cervical
cancer region
as you can see in this slide the
molecular biology of HPV infection is
quite extensive the long and short of
this slide is that in an uninfected
epithelium you get normal cycling of
cells without the appearance of any
oncogenes contributed by HPV however on
the right side of this equation when you
see an infection by a high-risk HPV type
you have a deletion of e7 and e6 uncle
jeans you have release from cell cycle
you get progression and eventually you
get invasion now this slide really
elucidates what can be done with
Diagnostics in this in this plot this
shows if you plot e6 e7 vs cell cycle or
proliferation that is being post g1 in
the cell cycle you can basically see
three populations of cells a population
of self that is you 67 negative that's
proliferating population of cells that
is e6 e7 positive but not proliferating
and then a population of cells it is e
67 overexpression and proliferating and
these actually define the different
categories as seen in a pap smear or in
a in a biopsy that is normal cycling
epithelium on the left and blue a
low-grade lesion which has early onca
gene expression but the morphology and
the dysregulation of the cell cycle has
not caught up with the overexpression of
the oncogenes yet so that lesion is
still in its early stages then of course
in orange later stage lesion
that result as the antigens are
overexpressed they knock out the tumor
suppressor genes and we see cell cycle
dysregulation and perforation now a lot
of this work was elucidated in Japan at
least as far as the role of e6 e7 and
cervical cancer and as you can see just
from the title of this paper ubiquitous
presence of e 67 transcripts in human
papillomavirus cervical carcinoma
regardless of its type and this paper
really breaks down the the the aura
around actually having a number after
the letters HPV we all know that 16 and
18 are probably the most virulent HPV
types in the world we don't necessarily
live in the 16-18 world hpv16 globally
is probably the most prevalent HPV type
that HPV 18 certainly is not the second
most prevalent unfortunately that's what
our our vaccines cover these days but
the take-home messages yes vaccines are
a good thing but at the end of the day
we're going to have to continue to test
until we have a polyvalent vaccine that
covers all 15 high-risk types but the
importance is that if you have a high
risk HPV type the definition of whether
or not it's it's going on to cervical
cancers whether or not it's
overexpressing mean 67 so only a very
small minority of those individuals
infected by high-risk HPV types ever go
on to high-grade pre cervical cancer
lesions or cervical cancer so we must
have ways to define which women with
high-risk infections are at risk it's
not enough just to say you have a high
risk infection
and then and then send that woman off to
invasive procedures to do follow-up
studies in fact in a large 600-plus
biopsy study we participated in recently
it was shown that if you did HPV DNA
alone the specificity for high-grade
disease was fifteen percent meaning
eighty-five percent of those women who
received biopsies didn't need them the
addition of looking at e 60 70 gene
overexpression however increase the
specificity to over eighty-five percent
she had a five-fold increase in
specificity for high-grade lesions just
by adding in overexpression of HPV
encoded oncogenes now we have a test as
a performance profile that is both both
effective for the patient and cost
effective this is another slide from
Harold zur hausen laboratory he won the
Nobel Prize in 2008 not only for
elucidating that HPV cause cervical
cancer but also the mechanism through a
67 by which cervical cancer was was
caused and a knee slide you see in a low
grade division there's only a few cells
overexpressing 67 this was in sight you
hybridization done on slides using
radioactivity in the early 90s but in
higher grade lesions such as sin 3 also
called carcinoma in situ in some of the
literature you see a quantitative
difference in the number of cells
overexpressing e6 e7 as represented by
the white dots in these figures so the
take-home message is cervical cancer
screening is a quantitative exercise
it's not enough to provide yes/no
answers
yes HPV DNA is there yes high risk HPV d
in their DNA is that yes e 67 is there
or not they're the key take home to this
is that you need to know how much how
much II 67 is being expressed on the
cell by cell basis and how many cells
are in a cervical region are over
expressive e6 e7 and you can see this in
the statistics comparing some of the
common tests that are out in the market
today where you have the hydrogen hybrid
capture to logic sir Vista the gen probe
optima and then the in cell DX architect
which actually quantify Z 67 they all
have similar sensitivities for
high-grade disease the big difference is
in the specificities in the positive
predictive values in other words using
Anka genes and biomarkers as a way to
triage and diagnosed individuals is
really the way to go about detecting
disease in my teachings I've always
talked about viral commensalism that is
much like bacteria and we've defective
VIII IV coli all over our GI tract we
have viruses growing in our body right
now and you know the response to that
myself being a virologist is who cares
they're viral commensals the big
question is is that virus contributing
to disease and is that disease treatable
manageable etc and in what timeframe do
we have to treat or manage for instance
you know a third of the people in this
audience may have rhinovirus or corona
virus in their nose to leading causes of
the common cold but we're going to go
give everybody eight hundred dollars
worth of ribavirin to get rid of those
viruses so the fact is we know viruses
are there
the question is are the virus is
actually doing anything here's a big
international study that showed the
difference between quantification of e
67 in the red square e 67 genotyping in
the triangle and HPV DNA in the diamond
this is an ROC curve with the ideal test
being in the upper left-hand corner and
the Euclidean distance being a measure
of test performance and clearly
quantification of e 67 and the highest
test performance of the three different
types of tests available in cervical
cancer screening for elucidating those
who have lesions that are concerning and
as you can see by the star the closer to
the star the better that's the ideal
test with a hundred percent sensitivity
and a hundred percent specificity they
we all like to achieve even though to
date we probably haven't achieved that
with any test now when you compare doing
a a quantification of oncogenes with the
presence of our absence of other
biomarkers you can see the differences
in sensitivities and specificities
versus other various tests are in the
market and some of them are slide based
which means your workflow is going to be
slower and obviously less throughput
being compared to doing 1618 genotyping
e6 e7 quantification and much higher
sensitivity for high-grade lesions with
similar sensitivity specificity and
positive predictive value now what's the
key differentiation of e 67 mrna from
just using HPV DNA in clinical
diagnostics well again as I mentioned in
a study in United States and 600 Bob
sees eighty-seven percent specificity
15 there's no loss of negative
predictive value it works with the
commonly used fixes that are out in the
market that's critical the other
critical fact is it's going to help
define the behavior of some of these
lesions associated with cervical cancer
I think it's it's commonly thought thats
into which is a high grade cervical
cancer lesion in sin 3 which is a high
grade lesion I'll go on to cancer but
it's quite the opposite about fifty
percent of sin tues regrets with only
five percent going on to invasion and
surprisingly thirty-two percent of what
used to be called carcinoma insights you
regress with around twelve percent or
slightly higher going on to invasion so
we have an opportunity lying within
these statistics to do a better job of
triaging which of these lesions by
histology do we really need to worry
about in terms of what we can do we call
this an architect family tree a standard
architect assay was is capable of
quantifying e6 e7 messenger RNA in cells
from the cervix 3dx were capable of
quantifying e6 e7 plus doing cell cycle
analysis aquatec 3d DXM we're also
capable of looking at morphology in
addition to cell cycle parameters and
oncogene overexpression and looking at
morphology and suspension so not having
to make a slide the majority of the time
spent in cervical cancer screening is
making and reviewing slides it's also
extremely labor-intensive and costly
however we now our technology where we
can actually look at the morphology
while the cells in suspension in
addition to that we're able to do all
these different plan
that is quantified e6 e7 messenger RNA
look at the nuclear the cytoplasmic
ratio which is probably the leading
parameter that pathologists look look at
on a psychology slide we can now provide
an objective digital estimation
nucleoside positive ratio without some
of the subjectivity that's introduced
during psychology we can directly
measure nuclear area you can look at
nuclear contour we can look at mean
corpuscular volume which is a
measurement of cell volume you can look
at the g one percent of the cell cycle
the post g one percent of the cell cycle
whether there's infiltrates of
polymorphonuclear neutrophils and
another interesting parameter in
cervical epithelial biology is the
nucleated to pick nautic cell rate as
squamous cells mature through the
epithelium they tend to lose their
nuclei that's the normal state in an
abnormal state obviously that's altered
and we don't see the loss of nuclei in a
typical normal epithelium so maybe
that's a parameter that can be exploited
to do a better job of high-throughput
determination of high-grade disease now
we can put all these parameters together
in bioinformatics models and combine
them as we see in this instance where we
can actually tell the difference between
cells that are HPV positive or HPV
negative without ever doing an HPV DNA
just by morphological aspects in
addition we can also say using
morphometric measurements here we see
the combination and going back to what I
was talking about is about
genius multiplexing here we're actually
doing an analysis a dot plot analysis
between a morphometric measurement
nucleocytoplasmic ratio and oncogene
over expression which clearly defines
normals which have low nucleus our
public ratio no oxygen overexpression
low-grade visions which have high
nucleocytoplasmic ratio but very little
oncogene overexpression and high-grade
lesions which have an abundance of cells
with high nuclear site of positive ratio
and oncogene overexpression what's great
about some of the current
instrumentation is that we can then
click on this population represented in
a numeric dot plot and say what are
those cells look like and as we can see
here they look normal so this is a
typical squamous cell which has a lot of
cytoplasm small nucleus no oxygen
overexpression round regular nucleon or
we can look at these high grade cells if
we wish and see bizarre shapes 867
overexpression pleomorphic inconsistent
nuclei that's characteristic of
cancerous and precancerous cells all on
an automated instrument all done in
three and a half hours without the use
of slides again this is just some actual
raw data this is a normal sample we see
no oncogene overexpression up here in
this quadrant we see normal-appearing
squamous cells no green over here we see
round regular nuclei all is good in this
normal sample we can see this abnormal
psychology where you see multiple DNA
populations and you see cells with e 67
over expression in the nucleus
as evidenced by the green skimming over
the nucleus in this particular cell
again all done digitally all done by
instrument without the use of slides
when we do this and look at this in
three-dimensional space using those
parameters we can clearly define these
blue cells which are normal cells versus
these red cells in the upper part of
this three dimensional graph which
defined high-grade cells and so without
ever looking at a slide we can
distinguish those two different states
of disease and normal last able to do
this on a two-dimensional plot as I
showed previously and define where we
are in cancer and pre-cancer genesis in
the inner circle circle up at the end
now the future is really the ability to
look at mRNA and combination with
multiple cell surface markers on intact
cells by flow cytometry or image
cytometry the uses labeled antibodies
followed by hybridization the
nucleotides mrna allows us to look at
mrna expression subsets of cells most
importantly we can look at multiple RNA
so our newer technology is much like a
gene in a chip in a Cell where we can
look at multiple genes of interest at
one time and their expression multiple
even a phenotypic markers on the surface
of cells so that we can unequivocally
identify cells that are highly
expressing genes related to disease and
and pick those cells out of
heterogeneous populations for instance
blood in looking for
activating tumor cells or in tumors
obtained by fine needle aspiration and
put into suspension in other words we
can multiplex we can multiplex the cell
surface markers multiplex intracellular
proteins multiplex mrna s all allow
looking at cell cycle armed with DNA
dyes and a lot of the current algorithms
for cancer certainly take into account
cell cycle genes and cell cycle markers
into their real time pcr algorithms for
instance i'm not going to go into too
much detail but again we can look at
mrna fold changes or particular genes of
interest in a cell type-specific way in
other words for the first time in
molecular diagnostics we have a
denominator when you take the current
path of molecular diagnostics of taking
a a cell sample lai Seng all the cells
and looking for gene signatures what
you're really doing is losing all
context from which those those jeans
came and again you're throwing them into
a commish and there is no denominator
you're saying is there a change in in
the gene signature and one of our
colleagues in california it showed
multiple times and papers that when they
are looking for gene signatures for
acute renal rejection for instance it
wasn't until they looked at specific
cell types and sorted specific cell
types that the gene signatures were
starting to make sense if you through
all the different cell types and blood
together what you really got was a
ganesh that clouded many of the
signatures indicative of disease so i
can't emphasize enough our philosophy of
needing a
a denominator that makes sense while
doing molecular diagnostics and again
this is just our renal transplant panel
showing variety of different dumb up
regulations of six genes all at the same
time and all in specific subsets of
lymphocytes in conclusion the you know
the upregulation of these various RNAs
are very very different depending on the
cell type it's important to know what
cell types you're looking at for
instance if you're looking at rejection
certainly cd8 + cd4 s are going to be
important part of cell-mediated immunity
and within those cell populations or
even subpopulations of those cell types
is where we're really going to see the
the gene signatures and differences in
gene expression with that out conclude
by saying that biomarker discovery is
rapidly moving with a variety of
different detection platforms we're all
for that you know recent reports suggest
that only a small population of all the
genes in a human genome contribute to
disease so you know why continue to look
for four whole genomes and more robust
platforms with high throughput and fast
turnaround times the more limited number
of targets regardless of whether they're
mRNA protein or DNA may be clinically
preferred and more cost effective while
managing disease and with that I'll
conclude and enter into the Q&A and
answer any questions thank you very much
so in the QA our first question from
Victoria is what is your opinion on the
HPV vaccine in relation to your findings
and research that's an excellent
question you know i'm all for the HPV
vaccine however it is it all
encompassing that still remains to be
seen my position with the vaccine has
been you know even from a cost
perspective is yes it's going to be
effective yes it's going to be effective
against HPV type 16 and 18 but there's
13 other types of cause cervical cancer
maybe to a lesser to grieve in 1618 but
nevertheless they caused cancer so we're
never going to do away we're screening
so now all of a sudden we've added the
cost of doing vaccine on top of the fact
that we still have to screen the
individuals regardless of whether
they've received a vaccine at least
until we we have more data to suggest
otherwise or else say we come out with a
with a polyvalent vaccine that covers
more of the high risk types in any way
and I'm not against the vaccine but is
it all encompassing in enough I don't
think so so we're going to continue to
focus on aggressive screening programs
and you know the fact you know the
success is in the facts and the facts
are that the United States has excuse me
one of the lowest rates of cervical
cancer in the entire world because of
its aggressive screening regimens always
has the rest of the world still cervical
cancer is still the second leading cause
of death in women so we know must meet
we can't solely commit down one path and
we need to continue to to proceed along
parallel paths to do the most effective
job
and keeping our women healthy the next
question again from Victoria is as a
woman I can tell you that I that having
a pap have helped prevent cervical
cancer and me when I was in my 20s
although just recently has been proposed
to restrict screenings your thoughts
well I I think the real question is some
of the new guidelines that have
suggested that if if your if your DNA
negative HPV DNA negative you might be
able to go to longer screening intervals
which i think is probably true what that
interval is I think has been the subject
of a lot of discussion and I have my own
thoughts on that now as far as the pap
smear is concerned what we have to
realize and what I've just shown in this
talk is that clearly molecular changes
of cervical cancer are happening well
before the morphologic changes occur and
conversely there's morphologic changes
that though they appear worrisome may
ultimately not be worrisome so I really
see in the coming years these new
technologies really replacing just a
straight morphologic examination of
cells it's going to take time it's going
to take money but it's going to happen
and in some populations in some areas
around the world it already is happening
where areas that don't have the
infrastructure to do pap smears I can
tell you from you know our worldwide
experience that the that pap smear
quality varies tremendously worldwide
which would be expected it's a
subjective reading of slides by and
numerous individuals
different levels of training so we have
to go molecular we have to go digital we
have to use ways that are reproducible
robust and non subjective this other
question from Linda what is the
rationale of multiplexing different
molecular types I don't know if that
means different molecular HPV types or
different biomarkers of cancer but as I
mentioned and as you can tell from my
talk I don't think when you know the
downstream markers involved in cervical
cancer that that result from the
integration of by certain high-risk HPV
types I don't see the importance of just
looking at HPV types I see the
importance of looking at variety from
markers ii 67 cell cycle or cell cycle
associated proteins and actually being
able to say where are you in the
continuum of cervical cancer and i see
she's added to the question in terms of
the rationale using DNA RNA and protein
types I'll tell you um you know we're
working on other assays such as
transplant and and breast where it's not
just RNA or it's not just proteins or
it's not just DNA one of the commonly
used algorithms out there in breast
cancer prognosis 21 out of the 24 genes
or cell cycle-dependent yet you know a
Penny's worth of a DNA guy can can do
similar things in cells in intact cells
and on a instrument that can give you an
answer in three to four hours
so and then of course the ability to do
that for instance with you know not just
portunity protein or her to New RNA but
potentially doing it for a number of
different proteins in rnase PR PR / to
new you know and DNA cell cycle you know
I think ultimately that's where the
field is going and to restrict yourself
to for instance an algorithm that's
dependent solely on rt-pcr or even
solely on sequencing a certain dnase i
think is not enough with the complex
cancer pathways that are out there
the next question from Rakesh is any
epigenetic biomarker related to cervical
cancer that your lab has come across we
you know we're we're not really going to
discuss certain certain biomarkers are
the ones we discuss today certainly none
that are ready for prime time
any other questions
but appreciate everybody's time and I
look forward to any questions that may
pop up after we sign off thank you very
much